o sarai tu siccome siamo vicini ad
halloween ho pensato di fare una
maratona di chi ha paura del buio
qualcuno se lo ricorda lo so che dovrei
fare una recensione ma non c'ho voglia e
poi non so neanche che fin potrei
scegliere dovrei prendere un film tipo
horror all'italiana uno di quei super
trash che non se ne vedono da anni una
roba tipo mezzo poliziesco mezzo non
aspetta so che firmare il film che
voglio recensire oggi la croce dalle
sette pietre ma prima facciamo un
viaggio mentale
torniamo indietro di quasi quattro anni
quando youtube era semi deserto e
c'erano le stelline al posto dei mi
piace
eravamo praticamente degli alberghi un
giorno di fine 2009 inizio 2010 carico
una recensione appunto del film la croce
dalle sette pietre ma che dopo tre
giorni mi viene rimossa per contenuti
pornografici
avevo fatto vedere un capezzolo 1 ma
siccome youtube e un verginello si è
imbarazzato e me l'ha tolta
sono passati tre anni e non ho mai più
rimesso quel video lì perché l'avevo
cancellato dal pc poca gente lo aveva
visto semplicemente perché all'epoca
avevo pochi iscritti e siccome io ho una
memoria equiparabile alla sedia su cui
sono seduto non mi ricordo assolutamente
nulla di quello che avevo detto quindi
prendo la palla al balzo e voglio fare
una specie di remake di quel video
voglio avere nella mia collezione di
recensioni la croce dalle sette pietre
capolavoro del 1987 diretto da marco
antonio andolfi partiamo subito
il film inizia con una scena di sesso
selvaggio
[Musica]
e no che mica sono scemo che gli mette
una scena del genere
siccome youtube a quanto pare si
vergogna di far vedere alla gente come
nascono veramente i bambini sostituiamo
la tutto questo ansimare questi q.li di
uomini imbarazzanti vengono fatti per
evocare un demone il demone amorim tra i
demoni più belli mai visti ed è
palesemente somigliante a vabbè tanto lo
sapete anche voi diciamolo insieme 123
assomiglia ad un vecchio anzianissimi
che non ha portato la protezione solare
giusta e si è ustionato in spiaggia no
no va beh ovviamente assomiglia
chewbecca dopo che gli hanno rovesciato
della cioccolata calda in testa ma
sempre giudecca e facciamo la
presentazione di marco il nostro
protagonista giunto da roma fino a
napoli per incontrare sua cugina carmela
tu sei carmela si sono proprio la tua
cara cugina e carmela sono tanti anni
che non ci vediamo come dai già da
quando eravamo bambini leggermente in
ritardo la risposta è
sembra come quando nei giochi sbagli la
risposta sono tanti anni che non ci
vediamo come stai
già da quando eravamo bambini mi trovi
un po cresciuto non potevo farne a meno
beh veramente trovo che sei diventata
una bella ragazza o marco abbiamo
iniziato da quattro minuti ci stai già
provando con tua cugina
that's amore spostiamoci in spiaggia
dove un ragazzo gigante sta per
spiaccicare due uomini piccolissimi
no non ho un cervello [ __ ] e la
prospettiva dell'inquadratura che fa
sembrare tutto stranissimo
e le prime due cose che fanno vedere di
napoli sono spacciatori e gente che
vende il pane io se fossi in voi mi
sentirei offeso
poi in un bar marco e carmela fanno
colazione ha intanto se non ti dispiace
e faccio una telefonata
sì quello è un gran bel pezzo di
tecnologia 1987 signore e signori fanno
letteralmente vedere ogni singolo numero
fatto guarda me lo segno caso mai
dovessi risultare qualcuno già numero
fai pure con comoda non ti preoccupare
ma che fai con calma anche tu non dargli
corda che qui finiamo a capodanno
sapete cosa manca per stereotipare al
massimo napoli nello scippo sei
fidanzata
chi lo santo manca solo pulcinella che
balla con in mano una pizza al suono di
libero e hai usato tutti i cliché sui
napoletani
fatto sta che a marco rubano una collana
e sogei anno si batta crede meravigliano
arrivata la polizia lo portano a cercare
i rapinatori al primissimo benzinaio in
cui si ferma lo guarda caso beccano due
dei quattro scippatori
quando si dice il culo momenti le mani
sul muro e non ti muovere senza marco li
riconosce ma loro fanno finta di non
sapere nulla
vuoi parlare una croce ma 9 cruz l'anima
de li mortacci tua ti riconosco a chi
legata alla mia presenza e mantova con
quelle recitazione gliela beppe l'anima
teleborsa se tu ma ti ricordo stop scena
dopo si ritrova a casa di una donna che
non è mai apparsa prima e salve
bongiorno scusami ti devo lasciare devo
andare da mia cugina chi è quel è così è
quella dove ciccia da fuori e l'on
nessuno mi risponde prova però non
perdiamoci marco deve andare dalla
cugina che cosa desidera mi scusi lei e
l'amica di carmela è veramente e carmela
sono io ma la prego si accomodi
scusi ma lei chi non la conosco scusato
tu sai chiaramente e sono marco tuo
cugino no fermi quindi quella bionda non
era sua cugina cassini sono proprio la
tua cara cugina e carmela
lei è quella vera e sono anni che mi
avevi promesso di venire a trovarmi ma
come mai non mi riconosco
detto da uno che poco fa ha chiesto
scusi ma lei chi non la conosca mi
sembrano domanda un po stronza questa
scopriamo però che la ragazza bionda in
realtà è elena un'amica di carmela e
quanto riguarda il motivo per cui è
venuta nel a prenderti credo di
immaginarlo
la colpa è mia l ho sempre parlato tanto
di te ma se poco fi detto che non mi
vedeva più da anni e dove siete va
ancora conosciuti scusi ma lei chi ama
la sceneggiatura mista
sono il male fisico ricapitolando marco
a una cugina di cui non ricorda le
sembianze carmela carmela parla di suo
cugino marco di cui non ricorda nulla
alla sua amica elena e l'enac si
interessa di marco si finge carmela per
conoscerlo e tutto questo a cosa porta a
carmela che si ritrova un ospite da
sfamare e marco che viene scippato un
applauso guarda caso elena è partita e
marco la cerca finisce in un locale dove
incontrò una terza altra ragazza ma se
falchi conta niente e no grazie è
purtroppo non si può fermare perché sto
cercando una breve ma sei passato
mezz'ora farci due palle così che dovevi
già carriera che devi cercare la
catenina dove senti rimorchia tela che
ti devo dire cercano una ragazza che si
chiama elena e cercare ma c'è un signore
che potrebbe aiutato questo signore che
la conosce è un capo della camorra
madonna santa marco ma che sfiga cia e
considero un bello giovanotte e sono
certa che sarei danga ragionevole ecco
alla bohrer inter
ecco cosa fanno i boss camorristi tutto
il tempo si vestono eleganti giocano al
solitario e sudano che pensavo molto
peggio gli fanno un'offerta in cambio di
informazioni
siccome marco lavora in banca il boss
buon una lista di clienti con i conti in
banca profumati voi vi procuriamo la
vostra grumi eboli gambi c dato un bel
elenco dei vostri kg
affare fatto no no io non vendo la pelle
degli altri a nessun prezzo
capito bravo marco rispetta la legge
non me la novità prendere i miei
collaboratori sono un poco male duca e
madonna con cui le violenze per fortuna
che in questa stanza completamente vuota
ci fosse un tavolino a caso da spaccare
la ragazza del bar raccoglie quello che
rimane di marco e non porta a casa sua
forse perché in mezzo a tutta quella
schifezza
tu lo sei l'unica persona pulita che ho
conosciuto marco si fa dare il nome di
un ricettatore della zona che potrebbe
avere la sua croce
lei è un cafone così emma ma mai pieroni
baldi e l'attore che appare spesso nei
film di fantozzi non ho neanche idea di
come abbia fatto a riconoscerla ho detto
la grecia ce battere ho detto che la
voglio comprare a qualsiasi prezzo
ma la croce non c'è si fa dare il nome
di chi l'ha comprata ma è troppo tardi
ora scoprirete perché marco ha rotto gli
zebedei così tanto per quella croce
stufi di entrarci moda apogeo bifest
[Musica]
[Risate]
non ce la faccio questo è oro una delle
trasformazioni più incredibili della
vita il design è qualcosa di così
ispirato che neanche gaither riusciremo
a fare una cosa del genere
mannaggia non ho idee su come fare il
costume e un costume da licantropo come
lo vuoi fare con le mani e metà faccia
pelose
ottima idea grazie ma non stavo
scherzando stavo scherzando ed ha il
potere di toccare le spalle degli
avversari scioglierli la faccia
ovvio
[Musica]
no non ho idea di come funzioni magari
talmente pieno di fico sita interna che
ne rilascia una parte sotto forma di
radiazioni in modo da sciogliere anche
più duro dei nemici
no forse è solo a caso magicamente marco
riesce a tornare a casa della ragazza
del bar con i vestiti addosso intatti
sono sicuro al cento per cento che ha
comprato nello stesso negozio dove
comprare o no la sequenza del sogno no
l'audio alla follia mentre dorme il
nostro protagonista soglia prove con un
filtro che fa male all'anima vede scene
passate future e colori per un tempo
infinito
[Musica]
sembra quasi di vedere una di quelle
video che siete tifo di king che mentre
lo guardi ti
[Musica]
il nonno
ma dicevamo durante il suo delirio marco
continua a ripetere il nome di don
raffaele esposito un altro capo
camorrista che probabilmente ha la sua
croce quindi parte alla ricerca ma a
quanto pare non prima di essersi
limonata una ragazza conosciuta mezza
giornata prima senza manco sapere il
nome a non giudicati perché l'avrebbe
fatto chiunque insieme vanno a cercare
don raffaele e siete voi che cercate da
una faele esposito sono qui per servire
sì sono io allora saliti ci penso io che
lo portano a casa del dolo che
ovviamente lo cattura ammanettate lo
marco è sì un po stupidi noè
io non capisco la ragione di questo
vostro comportamento è un boss della
camorra e ti chiedi perché ti abbia
catturato guarda secondo me è perché hai
delle sopracciglia fastidiose ma so solo
ipotizzando e mentre maria questo è il
nome della ragazza del locale cerca un
modo per liberare marco vi presento la
nuovissima sit com due scapoli a napoli
[Musica]
ma di mia moglie mi ha proprio stufato
con dita così tanti da sempre mamma io
ammazzo avere maradona ho finito il
primo ok non sapevo aspetto degli
investigatori iniziano ad investigare
sul cadavere del povero ricettatore a
questi poliziotti appariranno due o tre
volte durante l'arco del film senza
concludere nulla
io non me li farò più vedere e noterete
che il film funziona ugualmente anche
senza di loro non riesco a capire
sono ormai che lo tengono sotto torchio
ma grillo dice che sta cercando in
assoluto ma che resta croce ma una così
importante per lui a me o più umano
sembrano a muzzarelli
no aspetta ma forse quella croce che io
sono andato a prendere dato tonno o
cafone a ecco la croce stata regalata ad
un mignottone di periferia guarda
mancava la piega prostituzione in questo
film ho mai c'era tutto intanto il boss
picchia marco perché pensa che sia una
spia
e come se non bastasse arriva un altro
boss siculo americano unanime
baciamolemani avvalsa in arena ma ho un
uomo che dovrebbe avere due accenti e
non ne azzecca mezzo
l'onorevole ce l'ha mandata di persone
va da accertarsi che a sto pezzotti un
buon modo per insultare due paesi con un
personaggio solo diventa notte e maria
continua a tentare di entrare
nascondendosi nelle frasche
dire che da qui abbiamo fatto quasi
mezzanotte ma si può sapere quanto ci
vuole per vacan tasso romani nella juve
ci prova centinaia di mazzate dopo
scoppia il delirio
[Musica]
che problema c'è marco di più del naso
ma si sta trasformando ecco
[Musica]
e si sta trasformando
ci mette letteralmente due minuti per
trasformarsi due minuti che già lo so ma
per caso attaccato quello per te no la
maschera che poi non è neanche la stessa
maschera o mi ero dimenticato
particolare la foresta del pugnale
volante vedi che mi sa che chi è morto
un animale sul pube io mi farei
controllare per bere ma finalmente in
guerra oltre al potere di sciogliere le
facce e metterci 68 ere geologiche per
trasformarsi cos'altro sa fare
[Musica]
spacca tavoli sai che potresti lavorare
tranquillamente in wwe il costume già ce
l'hai quindi come faccio a prenderlo sul
serio
[Musica]
spettacolare gli sono ritornati i
vestiti compreso lo strappo alla manica
un tocco di classe veramente scopriamo
che la scena iniziale è un flashback e
che la madre di marco dopo aver fatto
sesso con il demone a purim dalla croce
il figlio e muore
ora si spiega tutto
marco porti per roma per trovare questa
donna dai facili costumi che ha la sua
dannatissima croce
[Musica]
carletto e smettila di giocare col
violino ma roma è grande e
fortunatamente una simpatica signora
decide di aiutarlo che c'avete da
guardare scusi cercavo una persona assi
e chi cercate giovanotto cerco la
signora armi sia la veggente ma li
mortacci sul camino tutte quelle no
signora io sono la madonna è andata a
morire ammazzata subito la prima strada
sulla sinistra salta subito voglio
questa signora sul mio comodino tutti i
giorni
si va dalla [ __ ] si fa sesso con lei
per ottenere la croce ma è troppo tardi
di nuovo
maria torna in tempo permettergli la
croce che ha trovato per terra mentre
arrivava a il culo ritrasformarlo e
vivere per sempre felici e pelosi ma ma
c'è ancora una cosa
l'uomo del flash back che invoca purim
appena viene dimessa la croce a marco si
schianta con l'auto e muore non viene
spiegato il perché mai nella vita
ma lui muore è stato fatto vedere solo
nei flashback
non sappiamo chi sia ma muore in qualche
modo era collegato a marco ma muore
poteva dare spiegazioni sul perché marco
si trasformasse in un uomo nudo ma muore
e dopo una scena di maria e marco a
spasso a roma insieme ad un cagnolino
spuntato fuori dal nulla appare gesù
cosa ci fai lì gesù spero che almeno ti
abbiano pagato bene come comparsa
quindi questa era la croce dalle sette
pietre
amen così anche voi potrete apprezzare
un capolavoro del trash come non se ne
vedevano da anni ormai è diventato
[Musica]
sono diventate la nuova edizione di
avellino si può dire la maschera
[Musica]
chiunque